[Music]  yep that's me I'm Ferdinand is like very  big your ginormous more of me to love  very strong ready to put those wings to  work  oh no you shot Maria into the Sun sorry  family pepper was the good boy  but the world sees Ferdinand is one  thing a fighter I gotta hear dis a big  double my hunts are my instruments eyes  are my arms next tips and buttocks no  I'll pass thanks you guys go ahead I  know exactly how certain it feels let's  go out there give 110% ahead actually  I'm gonna pass on the violence  to finally ready to fight come on I am  NOT a fighting bull the movie sends a  message that resonates very strongly  with me  don't judge a bull by his cover there  are places out there where you don't get  pushed around for being yourself heads  for one and everybody  [Music]  from the creators of Ice Age and we try  to be a little more the door to freedom  just do exactly what media  [Music]  [Music]